we fake your death in an apartment fire
i'll need three teeth from both of you
the other day i walked all the way to
maryland gorgeous that guy just pitched
me a cologne called i'm gonna tell
you what i told him not just anybody can
do this although it's a great name and
i'm probably gonna steal it don't mind
if i do i mean i can teach you guys how
to fake take real drugs like a pro i
used to do it all the time when i was
undercover all you got to do is close
your nostril when you go down watch this
oh nope
i didn't do it that time i got a full
snoutful
hey pimento huh i thought you were just
gonna be looking through the files or
something man sorry brother tai chi
helps keep the demons at bay right
and
do you have to do it in your underwear i
can't take them off cause then you'd be
looking right at my penis and testicles
can't argue with that logic
okay give me your booze i am nourished
by your hatred don't talk to eddie treat
him like you would treat a person in
another country that you paid
25 000 to hunt what are you talking
about what am i talking about talking
about the best vacation of my life
get my crossbow crossbow what hi there
hello
we need to talk we'll make it quick i
got to go pull the plug on my dad in 10
minutes
okay they got to knock that off i mean
what does weird energy even mean am i
right there are wind chimes where my
ding-dong should be
you can punch me kick me pull my hair i
am a-okay being stabbed biting and
scratching are on the table you can use
fire you know what shut up all right
janet this relationship has been the
best seven hours of my whole life
um excuse me pal thank you
squad meet detective adrian pimento he's
been deep undercover for the last 12
years but he's just resurfaced and he's
rejoining the nine-nine
that
is awesome
thank you for meeting with me mr fancy
please
call me dennis weinstein they claim that
smoking is bad for you
but is there any medical evidence to
back that up look at this glass oh my
god
sure you could slit his throat but then
what are you gonna do with all the blood
uh we just leave it in his body where
blood lives close the old nostroni and
then oh boy i got more that time
i got blood spurt ooh no don't use that
one hey go ahead ooh
i gotta go kill my dad let's go i have a
very funny story about keeping my eyes
moist
[Laughter]
nope
still not getting our vibe man really
snooze
you guys ever been fox hunting i have my
own foxes flown in from russia we drug
them pretty heavily so they can't get
very far in fact mostly they just flop
around on the ground makes it easier to
just walk up and bow
stupid foxes
it's deeply erotic you know what i just
realized i i forgot something at home
i'm just gonna
i'm gonna cut right to the chase i don't
like charity not to brag but i almost
have a full-grown penis now okay who is
hunter's buddy hmm
oh i was
oh crap
oh dennis what a mess you have 30
seconds to get out of this facility
[Music]
can you believe this
okay uh how'd you get in the apartment
oh it was easy i just seduced the old
lady upstairs came down the fire escape
jimmied the window open bing bang boom
i'm inside your living quarters totally
of course next time you could just give
me a call you know two ways to pop in on
a friend i didn't kill the old lady
upstairs if that's what you're worried
about this smells like somebody spilled
chinese food in a bird cage guys i'm
telling you the fake snorting can work
what
oh
[Music]
jason jason jason jason jason
jason jason jason jason jason jason uh
jason jason jason jason jason jackie
jason jason it's the only job i've ever
had except for back in groceries at the
supermarket at the corner of atlantic
and clinton
i guess i could go back to that again
paper or plastic yeah still got it we
need your help great who are we killing
i won't do kids that's a rule but that
rule is negotiable if the kid's a dick
can't even get a cup of coffee
and he's my current cfo but i might fire
him and hire you
you got kids no that's good dum-dum
eddie has two kids
fine single bag it it's your funeral you
dumb son of a get out of here
idiot you know if we pooled our
resources we could be done in two shakes
of a lamb's derrick i'm gonna turn that
place into an elbow art salon and make a
killing why trust none of these dildos
release the hounds what hounds the
hounds is an fda-rejected cologne i've
been working on that makes everything
smell like wet dog
after what i've seen
after what i've done
i don't know that i deserve to be happy
of course you do
huh
i never looked at it that way
wow
that changes everything the moment of
derek's creation and the eventual heat
death of the universe are now inexorably
the same come on jake you honestly
didn't assume i would hire a look-alike
to wear a fake beard and do tai chi in
my window no i definitely didn't assume
that plus you seriously thought that was
me i mean you see me in my underpants my
butt is rock hard that guy's got a
pancake bud michael michael michael
kleichel clycoclicle you should get
these kids out of here not to brag but
my clones have been known to stun human
growth so babe do you want us to beat
you up ah yes please anything to feel
alive i was lying before about enjoying
walking it sucks and maryland is a giant
pile of garbage sarge gave me some
really great advice
so
rosa diaz
will you marry me what this is what you
told me to do i barely said anything you
cut me off way too early wear whatever
you want as long as it's not too
bright or reflective you know i want you
blending in to the surroundings how fast
can you run
i think that guy wants to hunt me
yeah all right hey yeah do you guys play
an instrument you know i play a little
bit of bazooka anybody else play an
ancient stringed instrument no you guys
want to go to the beach it's a beautiful
day just maybe like get out there throw
the disc around right hey have you ever
been to the statue of liberty captain
have you have you been inside like under
the skirt like what's up there did they
build a you know what i'm saying ugh
guys watch this i'm gonna juggle them no
no no no no no no no
you